Hi I'm Kurt Braunohler and we don't have a lot of  f%#@ time so these are three thousand things absurdists love! Lets GO!
doll heads.
releasing seagulls at a wedding
slicing up eyeballs. HAHAHAHAHA!
giving people regular names nicknames.
Hey Seymore!  "Not my name"  that's my best friend Tim.
Repetition.
Doing magic tricks that aren't magic.
watch the quarter watch the quarter watch the quarter where's it going?
Wingdings the best way to say I love you.
Repetition.
Grunting while doing math
I both sitting weird
drive by sandwiching
hakuna matata
Asking football players, "how's the water?"
pipes in general.
talking to someone without looking at them
repetition, with slight variation.
Children's museums what are they? Their museums to children.
but there's children everywhere.
screaming god bless you.
GOD BLESS YOU!
Hey logan, how you doing? I f*%$# a statue once
kissing your own hand instead of the person you're greeting.
pleasure to meet you.
pooping an egg out your mouth
This isn't my house.
giving animals titles, Adventure Time, spelling things with hot dogs
bringing a balloons to a funeral.
ant hands. Did I say repetition? Yeah, repetitions definitely one.